خطوات عده تتخذها شركه ابل لفصل النظام
تشغيل الهاتف الخاص المحمول بها عن
الميزات التي تقدمها شركه الفابات الشركه
الام لجوجل ابل تخوض تجربتها منذ سنوات
بتطوير بتطوير كامل لبرامجها للسيامه
برامج البحث والاعلانات والخرائط الخاصه
بها هذه التطورات التي تعكس
ها ستكون
بمثل الذي يدوي في جوجل ليعلن حربا كانت
صامته لسنوات بين الطرفين هذه الحرب التي
بدات مع منافسه شرسه قبل سنوات حين
استحوذت جوجل على نظام تشغيل اندرويد
واصبحت منافسا شرسا لابل في سوق الهواتف
والاجهزه اللوحيه تفاصيل هذه الحرب مع هند
ابراهيم
من دون مقدمات دخلتها حياتنا واصبحت
امتدادا لذواتنا صديقتين عبقريتين تملكان
الاجوبه لاي سؤال والخرائط لاي وجهه
تختزنان عوالم وفضاءات تقرب البعيد وتمد
جسورا بين البشر لكنك لن تجد الموده
بينهما
[موسيقى]
تتنافس شركه ابل وجوجل بهدوء منذ سنوات
لكن طبول حربهما صامته بدات التدوي فشركه
ابل تخوض معارك لتعزيز خدمات ايفون وتفطمه
عن ميزات تقدمها شركه اوسبت الشركه الام
لجوجل
[موسيقى]
صحيفه
عن مهندسين سابقين قولهما ان صناعه ايفون
اعلنوا الحرب على جوجل من خلال تطوير
انظمه الخرائط والبحث والاعلانات
[موسيقى]
ها على جوجل اكثر فاكثر
تواصل جوجل توسعها وتطورها لكن الاكيد هو
ان الصراع بينهما يعني اننا سنحصل على
هواتف اكثر ذكاء واسرع واشد حمايه
لخصوصياتنا لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
يسعد صباحك اليوم ودوم يا فيصل اهلا بك
يا اهلا وسهلا صباحكم الله بالخير ودائما
بالسعاده يارب العالمين
مساله تعزيز بنفس التطبيقات وفصلها عن
النظام الاساسي شيء جدا ممتاز لكن دائما
في معادله التقنيات والتطبيقات هي اعلى
تبني المجتمعات لها اكثر من اي شيء
طيب فيصل بين ابل ستور وجوجل بلاي ايهما
افضل
ممتاز الحين كل واحد من الاثنين عندهم
كميه ضخمه بالمليارات الى التطبيقات ولما
نتكلم على هذه الكميه هي تخدم نقدر نقول
شريحه ضخمه من الناس بحسب احتياجاتهم لما
نيجي نقارن ما بين النجارين هتلاقوا ان
المقارنه جدا صعبه ولكن لما نجي ونخيب
المستخدمين فين المتجر يعني على حسب
احتياجاتهم هنعرف ان احنا نوصل لشيرين
مثلا لو تكلمنا عن اللوحيه اللي من شركه
ابل ولا ما انا عارف انه لايك اقرب لما
تجارهم انه فيها كم ممتاز من تطبيقات
الخاصه بالايفادات بس لو نيجي نشوف
اللوحيات حقات نفس الاندرويد والاجهزه
والانظمه اللي تشتغل عليها هذه اللوحيات
يمكن هنلاقي التخصيص الخاص ونقدر نقول
النوعيه الجيده من التطبيقات زي ما سويت
اعبل فهينا احنا نلاقي الكف على طول راحت
لعندها نفس الشيء في الجوال على حسب نوع
الجوال والمقارنه والمستخدم هنلاقي واحد
من المتاجر افضل من المست من الثاني طيب
اضافه الى الخرائط كانت الجبهه الثانيه
للمعركه بين جوجل وابل هي محرك البحث هل
يمكن لابل ان توفر نفس المحرك بنفس الجوده
ونفس السرعه لجوجل جميل جدا
كبيره انهم بالفعل تجيبوا شيء يبدل او
يخلي شريحه من المستخدمين يستبدل ليش يقول
هذا الكلام يعني انا تكلمنا على سفاري
المتصفح الرسمي من شركه ابل اللي موجود
على كل اجهزهم هذا المتصفح في الاعدادات
يقدروا يحطوا احد مواقع الرسميه اللي من
خلالها تم عمليه البحث بسهوله تخصيص هذا
الموقع وتغييره الى جوجل الى اي موقع ثاني
اي موقع يحتاج تدخل المستخدمين انهم يدخل
ويعدله الاعدادات فبالتالي هتلاقوا ان
شريحه ضخمه والمستخدمين ما يسووا هذا
الشيء طبيعي اول ما يجي الجوال يبقى يبح
طيب حيث خلصنا فبالتالي هذه الامر ممكن
جدا طيب من الاخر فيصل من له الغلبه في
هذه الحرب الصامته اليوم
لو تكلمنا على التاريخ اللي عندنا من عشر
سنوات وتبني التطبيقات اللي موجود في
المجتمع لكن ما في شيء يبدل يوتيوب ما في
شيء بدل خرائط جوجل مهما كثير من التطورات
اللي سويتها شركه ابل واعلنتها في
مؤتمراتها وبالفعل تطورات مره ممتازه في
الخصائص احيانا اقوى من اللي موجوده في
خرائط جوجل وبرده لو شفنا محرك البحث جوجل
انتشارها الضغط على اجهزه الاندرويد في
السوق كلها
لقينا لهم موضوع اقدر اقول الى الحين
الكفه ترجع لصالح جوجل
ضخمه من ناحيه الخصوصيه بان تجعل خصوصيه
المستخدم الكارت الرابع اللي من خلاله
المستخدمين ينتقلوا اكثر لا تقنيه ابل في
كل هذه الخيارات
ايامك دائما شكرا لك